[Music]
[Applause]
uh Rick neisel former college coach at
UCLA in Washington and Colorado now
works for CBS he joins us on the program
did we learn more about USC or Colorado
this past weekend Oh I think we learned
more about USC uh listen Alex Grinch has
been doing this for a long time with
kind of similar results they just don't
tackle well and until they tackle well I
don't know that they can be uh called
the favorite in the Pack 12 they're
certainly accomplished on offense Caleb
Williams is magnificent and does great
things almost every time out but that
defense is showing itself to be
vulnerable okay but explain that you
can't tackle can you change that during
the course of a season well I I I would
go back to how they practice I I just
you know everybody's trying to keep
every body healthy and we understand
that but somehow some way the tackling
in that particular practice and I if you
go back and watch practice film of the
Pete Carol days it was scrimmage almost
every day I mean they would just go at
it that isn't happening in this
particular deal otherwise you'd see
different results what do you see with
Caleb
Williams I see Patrick Mahomes I see a
guy that's uh just basically understands
certainly the play called but then loves
to play the play that he creates by
extension uh when he gets out and just
moves about and kind of has uh a sick
sense of where these guys are going to
end up being and can throw them open
he's he's
magnificent Dion Sun shador it feels
like there's a coming out party at least
there was Mel Kyper goes oh you know
he's going to be a first round draft
pick is he on the level with Caleb
Williams he's close uh he's been
terrific and and his his ability to to
make every platform platform throw is
has been really fun to watch as well uh
going to his left going to his right the
changing trajectories despite arm angles
go back to that TCU game that fourth
down play where a guy got in his face
and he had to basically drop one over
the top to the kid in the flat that was
a fantastic play and uh something you
can't script he just has it so uh he's
right there how would you grade Colorado
season so
far off the charts I think Rick George
the athletic director at Colorado has to
going to have to have surgery to get the
smile off his face I I can only imagine
what his face looked like when he was
telling the student body not to storm
the field you
know he was going you know fingers
crossed over here on his left hand as
he's writing it with his right listen it
has been Magnificent the amount of
attention that the program has gotten
and the amount of eyeballs that have
sitting there and watched the campus in
Boulder whether it be on you know big
noon or game day that is invaluable for
the brand for recruiting purposes uh
listen getting a phone call from Prime
would be awesome as a kid but watching
that you want to be a part of it and
Colorado is going to reap unbelievable
benefit in the recruiting world because
of it we're talking to Rick neisel CBS
sports college football analyst former
College head coach um
who are the great teams in college
football this
year I think Texas is on the verge of
being a great team which is why this
Texas Oklahoma game this week is really
interesting you know quietly we're
talking about lots of quarterbacks you
just mentioned a couple Caleb Williams
and shador Sanders Bo Nicks Michael
penck out there in the west coast having
monster years uh this kid Dylan Gabriel
is having a big- Time season quietly
because the conversation has been the
transformation of their defense he's a
75% passer I think he's got uh you know
something like 14 touchdown passes
against just two picks I mean he's
playing magnificently over 300 yards a
game so this uh game with him and Quinn
yers is going to be one to to behold
what do you make of arch
Manning he's you know Biden his time he
has the luxury of a family that
understands patience he has the luxury
of a family that needs nothing in the
way of attention they just are going to
wait their turn I think Quinn ERS is
going to Vault uh he was my pick to win
the Heisman uh he's gonna have some
stages here coming up Texas fans are
craving this kind of attention uh this
is uh going to be fun but Arch Manning
is sitting there watching this all
develop and while Colorado is going to
reap a bunch of recruits so too will
Texas as sarc has got things going has
college football moved up to Georgia's
level and Alabama's level or have they
dipped down a little bit maybe a little
bit of both uh you know Georgia I at
first I believed it was Georgia just
kind of going through the doldrums of
preseason you know nobody really have
note to play nobody really get fired up
so many good players trying to make sure
everybody was happy getting their their
chances to play uh but now that they've
kind of focused on Brock Bowers they're
back going again I thought it was crazy
that aubert didn't have some plan to
bracket him because Hugh frees really
had a chance in that game but in the two
SEC games they've been behind in both
halftime at the South Carolina game they
were sitting there down 143 and then
this game
1710 uh in the second half it was uh
they've come back down to earth which
makes the SEC really fun to watch right
now go back when you were coaching did
you coach against a player that was just
Unstoppable like you didn't have an
answer whether it was offense or defense
Ricky
Williams Ricky Williams at Texas when I
was at Colorado was a handful I mean
goodness gracious was he was he
fantastic uh I remember John Elway at
Stanford you know that was one of my
playing days we couldn't we beat them
3835 and just we're so thankful that the
clock ran out you just couldn't stop
Elway when he got going so yeah I've
been on I've been on some stadiums where
it looked that way I noticed you slipped
it in that you beat Elway yeah noticed
it well it wasn't me it was it was Tom
Ramsey I had good view from the
sidelines the clipboard yeah I had the
clipboard in that one day oh describe
Elway in college he's John Wayne he's
gonna come in and save the towns people
you know uh he's he's gonna he rides
into town and he just had that
swashbuckling feel about him and such a
big arm that he' break contain he had
that patented you know give you the
front shoulder then back out the other
way and then get all the way over to to
the left side of the field and throw
back to some Stanford you know walk-on
receiver over on the out side and you're
going how did he do that but uh as far
as but he but ultimately his his chief
weapon was he believed that something
good was going to happen at the end of
the game compare his ability uh momes
Rogers Elway anybody else you want to
throw in there just the ability to play
quarterback they have taken it to the
level where they manipulate you they're
not dealing with manipulation they
manipulate you they get to a place where
they know exactly what's going on on the
opposite side of the ball so they have
what they want in the pre- snap but they
have such unique confidence that if it's
not good they'll sit and wait for their
little pocket or seam in the pocket to
uh uh to open up and then they'll escape
to a spot which now creates the second
play in their little Weaponry which is
the extended play and now they just
start firing darts at you and you're
just holding on for dear life I haven't
spoken to you since uh the uh Pack 12
was
decimated your thoughts on the burial
I've been looking for the candle in the
vigil you know in in your on your set
there yeah it's it's sad we're down to
the pack two and I think everybody who's
got any Soul at all is pulling hard for
both Oregon State and Washington State
to get everything to get the kitten
Kaboodle to just keep all the assets and
to find some way to incorporate with the
current Mountain West and I love the
idea that they're trying to bring this
relegation and promotion idea from
European soccer because that to me is
the way to save the rest of college
football if we can find a way to get the
a group of five to have a way to you
know get promoted to the power five uh
in the future of this super two that
were're entering I think that would be
wonderful for the game it would put a
spotlight on more players and keep more
scholarships uh which I think is the end
goal good to talk to you as always thank
you bud my man Rick DP Rick new
neisel